alors à tout cela il faut ajouter des
instructions préventive donner à la
population de minsk par exemple les
enfants n'ont plus le droit de jouer
dans les cours d'école et interdiction
est faite à tout le monde à tous les
habitants de ne plus boire de lait frais
de ne plus se baigner dans les rivières
pour sa part le savant soviétique
dissidents jaurès medvedev estime que la
nièvre risque un empoisonnement durable
ainsi que certaines zones côtières de la
mer noire bref on commence juste à
mesurer l'étendue cette catastrophe
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons invité monsieur le professeur
ramade parce que vous êtes un
spécialiste de géologie et d'écologie ne
regardait pas vers là c'est plutôt vers
moi qu'il faut regarder parce qu'on voit
votre image dans le dans le récepteur et
vous avez donc monsieur le professeur
ahmad examiner de très près tout ce qui
se passe là bas
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
la catastrophe écologique est réel
pour l'instant nous sommes absolument
dans l'incertitude des quantités de
radioactivité libérée
néanmoins réacteurs comme celui de
tchernobyl renferme dans son coeur
environ 90 tonnes d'uranium enrichi est
l'équivalent de plusieurs centaines
d'ong de protons de bombes atomiques
type hiroshima
en ce qui concerne un produit de fission
normalement cela aurait dû être confinés
mais il n'ya pas paraît-il d'enceinte de
confinement à ce réacteur
de sorte que si on a la configuration
maximale de l'accident c'est à dire
fusion totale du coeur une quantité très
considérable de produits de fission est
susceptible de se répare rendre
l'environnement
est-ce que les informations que j'ai
données concernant la population de
minsk pour vous était un indicateur
cela prouve sans doute qu effectivement
les pertes sous forme gazeuse vapeur
d'eau et surtout iode radioactif ont été
très sensibles
il faut savoir que l'yonne en effet est
un composé qui naturellement ça rend
vers s'accumulent très rapidement dans
la thyroïde en quelques heures
80% d'une dose absorbée se retrouve dans
la thyroïde et c'est cela en cela que
risque dans le premier col haut risque
dans un premier temps et très
considérable vous avez déjà eu des
contacts avec des savants soviétique
depuis cette catastrophe sur une
information est vraiment en 10 90 a
absolument pas mais ce en quoi je suis
très préoccupé c'est de savoir dans
quelle mesure il ya eu libération de
produits de fission du coeur type le
césium 137 ou le strontium 90 qui eux
peuvent s'accumuler dans les sols passa
ensuite dans les chaînes aliments
terre en propre dans les productions
agricoles et ensuite dans les
productions animales
est ce que l'on peut considérer que
cette catastrophe écologique si c'est le
cas peut avoir des répercussions sur le
monde entier c'est à dire devenir
quelque chose de mondial
absolument pas quand même une fille il
faut relativiser la faire par exemple il
faut savoir que les niveaux de
radioactivité mesurés dans les pays
occidentaux sont inférieures au maximum
qui a pu être mesurée à l'époque on
faisait des essais de bombes à hydrogène
dans l'atmosphère donc de ce point de
vue là il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
absolument pas pour que pour ce qui
concerne l'union soviétique j'ai créé le
plus préoccupant ce sont les
conséquences alors en long terme parce
que je le répète ses produits de fission
par exemple le césium 137 est très bien
fixées par les sols chaque gramme de sol
pour retenir si curie de césium 137 une
bonne dose de radioactivité fabuleuse
alors ensuite ces produits vont se
concentrer dans la chaîne alimentaire
patients dans les plantes passant dans
les animaux domestiques qui les consomme
rond et on arrive ainsi dans les viandes
et dans les laits par exemple à des taux
de césium et de strontium qui lui
s'accumulent dans les eaux alors que le
sodium s'accumulent dans le muscle qui
peuvent être très considérable et
atteindre des seuils tels que la
production agricole ne soit pas
commercialisable selon les normes de
radioprotection des populations que nous
comment peut-on lutter contre cela une
fois que le mal est fait ce qu'il y à
hélices ya des moyens de lutter quand il
s'agit d'une contamination limité on
peut éventuellement lutte et essayer de
décontaminer mais quand il s'agit d'une
pollution dispersés sur neuf as tu
refasses même si les concentrations
immédiate ou ne provoquent pas une
radiation mortelles
ou dangereuses des gens vivant dans le
voisinage il n'empêche que le mal est
fait et il faut attendre que la
décroissance radioactive et fait son
travail pour que les produits
radioactifs disparaissent de
l'environnement et le césium par exemple
à un temps de demi vie de trente ans de
32 ans
quand vous voyez à peu près
le risque que cela présente je citerai
pour terminer une dernière référence la
tente des niveaux et tant qu êtres où
les américains ont fait leurs tests
danger nucléaire dans les années 50 et
aujourd'hui encore on à moitié
inhabitable par suite de la
radioactivité résiduelle
c'est à dire plus de près de 40 ans
après je vous remercie monsieur le
professeur ammann de nous avoir éclairé
sur cette situation nous aurons
certainement l'occasion d'en reparler
avec vous merci d'être venus